welcome welcome here are your new  company laptops David you can't wear  that it's a girl color oh here give her  pick that will that way yeah yeah that's  cute see ya no no no no no David can do  that  I've never done that before how's yours  it's a manly no no no no no I have  something better okay so let's start  looking over the presentation if you  guys wouldn't mind cleaning up when  we're done that'd be great  Natalie up a little Bobby if you guys  could clean up after we're done that  would be great good leadership David  okay boys will be boys my favorite  colors blue actually really like pink  oh my god stop wait oh oh honey no you  want me in my bed baby we got that for  you oh that's okay Hey yes it's good  thanks